bonjour m et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france à leur première
question dans quel état se trouve
aujourd'hui votre cliente après cet
épisode
écoutez elle est assez choqué puisque
elle se rendait simplement
à une manifestation elle souhaitait
exercer son droit à manifester
et finalement avant même d'être arrivé
sur place a été interpellé par des
fonctionnaires de police qui lui ont
notifié son placement en garde à vue et
elle s'est retrouvée effectivement
durant 24 heures revenus privés sa
liberté d'aller et venir et finalement
déféré au palais de justice le lendemain
alors vous avez porté plainte contre x
pour arrestation arbitraire comment
expliquez-vous que vous deviez enfin que
voilà la personne que vous représentez
n'a commis aucune infraction
apparemment et elle a été tout de même
déférés devant le palais de justice
écoutez justement c'est assez
incompréhensible parce que finalement on
considère que
elle aurait pu commettre cette
infraction c'est à dire que on est en
train d'imaginer ce qu'elle aurait pu
avoir dans sa tête au moment elle
semblait cette manifestation et puis
pour certainement dissuadé la dissuader
et dissuader d'autres infirmières de
manifester eh bien on sait qu'on portait
quant à son encontre de la façon la plus
brutale qui soit c'est à dire en la
considérant immédiatement comme une
comme une personne comme une délinquante
et une personnes qui souhaitaient
commettre une infraction à ce moment là
donc naturellement j'estime que
l'objectif d'une garde à vue ce n'est
pas de dissuader des gens d'exercer leur
libre droit à manifester quand on
considère qu'il ya des infractions
commises il ya pour cela un droit pénal
est propre et elle s'applique enfants
constate une infraction
alors que reproche-t-on concrètement à
votre cliente la police évoque des
objets interdits aux manifestations
alors on lui reproche simplement d'avoir
eu une blouse d'infirmière avec elle
d'avoir eu un masque de protection
avec elle et des lunettes de protection
voilà voilà ce qui lui est reproché
c'est à dire uniquement des éléments qui
servent à se protéger dans l'hypothèse
où il rainer jets de gaz lacrymogène ou
autre mais aucun objet offensif n'a été
retrouvée sur elle ni barres de fer ni
lance pierres ni mortier absolument rien
qui lui permettait d'exercer des
violences à l'encontre de fonctionnaires
de police ou envers d'autres
manifestants donc en réalité uniquement
des éléments qui servait à se protéger
sachant qu'elle avait qu'elle a des
problèmes de santé et que dans cette
hypothèse elle souhaitait pouvoir éviter
bien d'être blessés dont peut-être la
manifestation devait dégénérer tout
simplement est-ce que vous avez
connaissance d'autres dossiers d'autres
manifestants qu'ils seraient dans le
même cas que votre cliente alors il doit
y en avoir puisque ces contrôles sont
effectuées sur la base de réquisition
du procureur de la république de paris
et d'ailleurs votre parquet de province
en ce qui me concerne je n'ai été saisi
pour le moment que de son cas mais
naturellement il est important me
semble-t-il que les personnes qui font
l'objet de ce genre de garde à vue est
arbitraire et bien se manifeste et
exercent leurs droits a déposé une
plainte en considérant tout simplement
qu' ils sont victimes de leur de ce type
d'agissement de la part des autorités
alors que va-t-il se passer maintenant
et quelles sont les prochaines échéances
pour votre cliente après le dépôt de
plainte
nous attendons que le procureur de la
république nous indique quelle suite il
entendait j'espère qu'une enquête sera
ouverte et j'espère que cette enquête
aboutir à des poursuites merci beaucoup
en tout cas tarek quand athènes d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
de versailles en charge du dossier de
cette infirmière à la retraite